hey everyone it's Tom here a voice you
don't normally hear on the channel we're
here going through Doomsday Clock that's
a reason I'm here it's finally over
everything ends
is said towards the end of this book and
you're thank God
it has concluded this is the last of the
dozen of the Geoff Johns Gary Frank
weird quasi sequel thing has had such a
long gestation period that another weird
quasi sequel thing has came out and
actually finished before this year drop
which is crazy and a whiff death death
has a coma how's it going everyone
thanks for checking out the final
installation of watching The Watchmen
thanks for all the people that have you
know stuck with us through their
childhood growing up over the last three
years we thought it would be a very very
short podcast but nope Geoff Johns had
other plans so yeah we've we've been
here for three Christmases almost maybe
longer and yeah longer actually because
it came out 2017 the towards the end
like I still remember buying the first
issue and yeah we were saying this is
gonna be like a watchman thing you know
it was so cool it's gonna be month by
month in this story and I mean we last
spoke like three four months ago or
something like that like it's just it's
taken so long it's taken what II too
long yes like you said with the HBO show
it's crazy to think that they managed to
do an entire series film and edit it
cast it write it and so on in the time
that it's taken to do a 12 issue comic
book hmm yeah I don't know what's been
going on that DC but very very strange
very strange Tom what what has been
going on the thing everyone thinks that
dr. Manhattan at DC taken their time
with stuff you know I mean yeah maybe it
was maybe it was held back slightly you
know to capitalize on the Watchmen stuff
but I don't think they have that force I
really and I don't really understand why
boy it's taken that long and you know
it's been so long I hope guys you go
back through the old issues the old
episodes if you want like a detail recap
because I barely remember
the hell's going on like this was quite
I had to read a few recaps beforehand to
feel coherent going in like yeah and
this issue is well it is sort of all
over the place once more so I just
wished they'd written like a simpler
story almost like the the HBO show very
simple on the surface but very dense
once you start getting into it and this
is just very dense in its so it's a bit
hard to follow even the ending of this
is still a bit up in the air there it
was attempted to do and then Dan
explained birth order come I can't be
bothered with it so I'd rather explain
the ending of the garage you know what I
mean Tom get those that add revenue in
every way do it again the ain't ending
of Jumanji to like you know oh you've
got it really when they do a
post-credits scene as well tom you've
got to explain that okay okay you've got
to so well should we get into this
should get into this final issue which
you know one of the things we haven't
really criticised throughout the run and
again I want to say it's pretty cool the
cover
you know the cover clearly playing on
the idea of the blood splatter on the
comedian badge now it's being the yellow
of Superman chest and this is you know
quite a close-up you can kind of
appreciate the scratches and nulls and
you know it's simple this really is a
great image just to sort of sell the
series as a whole but I quite like it
yeah great cover and you know what I bet
this image is something that came they
came up with early on yes they probably
thought we should have Superman fight
dr. Manhattan a bit oh yeah put the
blood stain on the yellows s and I like
do it Go Go make it twelve series come
of that probably that's what I would
guest on and then they realized they
didn't have much of a story to tell
because a lot of this stuff and we have
been saying this it feels like two
separate storylines like even the the
tray that's been released it's in two
parts actually got the the first
hardcover the other week and it's weird
that they've kind of separated it up but
it does feel very disjointed and someone
a Korra member who was but they said
that if HBO's Watchmen feels like a
sequel to The Watchmen whereas this just
feels like a DC comic
book story with the Watchmen characters
in it does it does and all these
horrible event mechanics that they're
just shoving down here is what it's not
allowed to exist his own story it's like
we're gonna get to the resolution of you
know if there wants to be a flu line
early on you know you would think okay
at least we're gonna find out what
happened to Marion our minds kids and
you kind of do but then they're not
given closure which we'll get to which
kind of forces them back into the story
and yeah it is just I mean at this point
this should be you know think about the
final issue of Watchmen really all the
kind of action goes down and issue
twelve and we kind of a lot of the the
scenes turn up which we kind of have
here but we haven't had much big action
but getting into the book I mean if you
are gonna do you know a parody of
Watchmen the easiest way to do it is to
say it's nineteen forty five five
minutes from now X is gonna happen in
twelve years did or did order the dirt
and it's like John's can't help but
indulge in himself not pushing the story
really forward at all just kind of
recapping over more like flourish yeah
he's sort of it is sort of riffing on
the original Watchmen graphic novel but
it feels like stuff we've all seen
before and it's not I'm not invested in
the story as much here so I don't really
care that it's repeating like if you're
if the best part of your story is just
remember when this happened and that
book that you like yeah it's kind of
like and it starts up and I was wrong
everything ends so immediately it
contradicts the ending of Watchmen and
and also I kind of feel like dr.
Manhattan's very absolute so he wouldn't
be wrong because he can see he's very he
doesn't consider things right and wrong
it's just very absolute this is what
will happen blah blah blah
I don't have an opinion on this he
doesn't have an opinion so he can't be
wrong no I mean exactly yeah there's one
thing that happens is we're gonna get to
in Superman and Manhattan faceoff which
is very much the more for moment the
banner listen which out outraged me like
that completely contradicts the
character of dr. Manhattan similarly I
was wrong everything ends like we said
before doctor hands one of the most
interesting characters
in the history of the written word
beautifully put together way more he's
he's contradictions and his paradoxes
and just his pure omnipotence and yeah
John's is just treating him like anyone
else really and and and for that it
suffers so yeah we have all this stuff
we have the picture that we see this
mysterious photo that appears whenever
dr. Manhattan does something plot wise
that's again not really explain I think
it was touched on before but you know
we're getting to the money shot I
suppose on your page well that's what
they kind of advertise this as it wasn't
it like Superman versed on Manhattan
gonna fight which do you care Tom I mean
no suppose 2014 yeah yeah it reminds me
of like when I was a kid I used to get
all those you know Marvel essentials I
don't if you remember those they were
kind of like soft cover my and they are
like the first 20 shoes of spider-man
and daredevil and stuff like that and
they you know they're really cool to go
back through but all the covers would
often be like you know the Hulk vs. for
like who wins kind of thing and it's
like I don't know it's 2019 like it's
fun to sort of riff about in a pub but
in terms of a narrative I want something
a bit meteor I don't know yeah I feel
like we kind of have went through the
whole vs. phase like we had Civil War
and Batman V Superman you know at this
point it's like Wars and yep yeah you've
had your heroes fighting your heroes and
that was in the mid 2010 s that was a
very interesting thing but it's 20/20
now tom and it's still like it was
Superman who did this feels like the
scraping the barrel of this is like
showdowns you know I mean like well I
haven't had dr. Manhattan V Superman
yeah who would win which we all know
we've known but I don't know how like
Batman V Superman was always a kind of
interesting debate because it was like
well you know Superman would hold back
and Batman he's very smart he would plan
ahead and ever yeah where is dr.
Manhattan you just fit well you'd wipe
the floor with him it wouldn't a guy
like Superman couldn't even punch him if
he if dr. Manhattan didn't want him to
he could just materialize and
dematerialize and whatever it wouldn't
be a fight it wouldn't be a fight
basically so as you're off your off the
board no Superman you're dead but yeah
yeah yeah I think comic books in general
are kind of falling back into this whole
sort of cliche of I want to see two
characters fight to see who's gonna win
when there can be so much more than that
and they're going back to what they were
which Alan Moore was able to pick up and
completely deconstruct in the original
graphic novel The Watchmen I mean
they're kind of falling back into that
almost and going back to normal Silver
Age aesthetic yes without any real irony
though yeah like more more would revisit
those things in 1963 his image series
which I love were you know instead of it
being four he does Osiris the Egyptian
gods and lays all that idea
whereas here no you're right here it is
being quite sincere and just you know
putting the toys in the sandbox and
putting them together and on this street
we have all these Freud's coming
together it was slowly reassembling in
my brains and we have the Russia stuff
and then we hear a can that stuff and
there we are so it's kind of like on
this little corner of the world yeah you
know the plots - yeah yeah just
everybody's fly and it's funny you say
before at the Silver Age stuff because
definitely at the bottom of page free
with Superman in the middle and everyone
going towards and like that looks like
an old-school cover yeah it does and
like you said they're not doing it
ironically or you know pastiche it
this is a very there's a brilliant bit
in The Watchmen graphic novel where
Night Owl and Silk Spectre or
reminiscing about that super villain
that used to confront them and be like
punish me punish me and you know in
enacting Carnac captain carnage
everything he was called yeah and and in
comic books in the 70s what would have
happened would have been there would
have had a fight on a street corner and
what was funny about that conversation
was that they talked about Rorschach and
how he just dropped him down an elevator
shaft
he just killed him outright which was
very like sort of anti superhero and
anti comic books at the time whereas
this is kind of going back to it we know
they would have a big fight in the
middle of the city on the corner of the
street which I don't
yeah like this I mean there's people
showing up to fight Superman
no one's really asking who dr. Manhattan
is suggest all we're here to fight
Superman and some of us are here to
stand with them they're not like trying
to talk with a guy who has been very
reasonable for decades like Superman he
saved the world for decades but like I
want to kill you Superman I know you've
been a great guy for the past 40 years
but we're not gonna talk it out or
anything you're dead mm-hmm
yeah it just it goes against all
instinct and again it shows no real
forward planning and it just yeah you're
not invested because it's a very flimsy
characterization and you know we're
cutting back and forth from back and
forth because you know if you remember
at the back of one of the issues when I
have all this stuff which is probably my
favorite information that we got was
kind of the metahuman map of the world
and you know we learned about the
aboriginal idea and their Israeli
metahuman program and we sort of see
things here and there and whatever and
again you know we roll our eyes at how
John's is so [ __ ] a juxtaposition
there's the word that more was so
brilliant but Superman searing is heat
vision for a pitch-black demon and it's
saying I cannot see through the barrier
of darkness is yes it's on the nose
definition on the nose Mary yeah and
there's no stability in the storyline
there they also have a bit with
Rorschach where they they sort of try to
introduce racial politics for a second
yeah but unlike HBO Watchmen which which
centers heavily around racism and so on
doesn't really feel owned or even where
the stories at it's just to show that
some people are racists and it's not
it's not integral of the plot
it's just somebody some people are
racist you know where is Watchmen what
was it did have that plot aesthetic but
the plot was built around it whereas
this is just a white guy showing up to
hit Rorschach over the head with a pipe
noticeably a white guy over red hat yeah
good spot yeah which yeah I mean cuz
yeah there's so many Magor Trump
illusions for out this is why we've
Robert Redford as the president and all
the Russian stuff that's blowing up and
you know that cut I'm pretty sure Iran
is mentioning this so I thought if jung
geun's had the foresight the sort
deal with that but yeah lots of stuff
could be free I I did notice the Red Hat
just cuz it's quite prominent like yes
clearly you know draw your attention to
it like even when Alfred's grabbing his
wrist it's pretty much in frame like
yeah no you're completely right I missed
that I should have just thought he was
doing a Fred Durst impression thought he
was a big limp Biskit fund baby they're
probably both it's probably a cease and
a biscuit ban likely but the limp Biskit
heavy spoilers fans they're not bad I
don't mind wise ballin on guitar but
yeah we have this Reggie and Alfred have
some past right I can't really recall
them anymore would take everyone yeah he
did he did yeah yeah yeah yeah so he
goes to recruit Rorschach like how do
they know where he is what's he doing
there oh yes just events happening here
rather than character development I feel
mhm I don't really feel the drama
because there's nothing to be invested
in it's just very much here's what's
happening that without you know thinking
about the logic behind it like I said I
wouldn't [ __ ] on the rights of Skywalker
any more Tom but I'm gonna [ __ ] on it a
bit that film is very much events are
happening but there's not really a
reason for them happening it's just kind
of right throwing it at this viewer and
I feel like this is what's happening
here yeah this we've said this before
like where wasn't the cops that the the
Matt Maria and mine were in their
childhood and we said those should have
been the cops that investigate comedians
murder
yeah and it's like you know maybe Reggie
should have been back at the mental
asylum where Mothman was an Alfred knew
that he loved him and that would have a
case but yeah you're right
Alfred just happens to meet myself and
you can actually see on page seven in
the middle I ran a new around was there
a writer Superman a war criminal about
to make an example of the American hero
cheese so you think yeah this all
started the war Tom maybe maybe I think
I think Sula many was more of a Marvel
dude so that could have could have cost
it over but um you know and we do get
these splash panels which are gorgeous
and enormous and you can't help but
pardon upon marvel at them but yeah
Alfred is there and you know with no
hope is spoken of as well and we're
cutting between
back through all our characters we're
getting some sort of you know rule
shares but it's kind of there's just way
this way too it's so wide but so shallow
like there's so little I'm invested in
here and it can become quite it's almost
like that splash panels quite almost a
representation what's happening
narrative Lee it's just so much combat
but very little that's that's sticking
you know right there's very little
scenes that really linger in the brain
and want you to read forward yeah
exactly it's just throwing everything
that I can there's too many plot threads
going on and they're trying to resolve
them all in this issue Watchmen that
well Doomsday Clock I think probably
would have been best as a longer series
you know don't set yourself a time limit
on it just be like it'll end when it
ends like most comic books do that they
just have the teller story in the time
that they need to and this sets up so
much and then just tries to tie it all
together and it doesn't really work and
you know we do keep saying that Watchmen
the graphic novel was every issue was
basically centered around one character
and you would see certain events from
their perspective such as the
crimebusters meeting the comedian's
funeral you know it would be the same
sort of events playing out from
different perspectives so that you had
an anchor in that world that you could
attach to and then it's all developed
the story from there but there was very
much a dr. Manhattan issue a Rorschach
issue and Ozymandias issue where's this
it's just every characters getting a
panel or two and they're supposed to be
developed in that like dr. Manhattan if
written badly like Superman he can be a
very uninteresting character and here
you have them both at the most
uninteresting going head-to-head now
yeah Superman is interesting because
he's got the ultimate power and he has
to wrestle with doing the right thing or
you know saying I don't want to do the
right thing here he's not really doing
that and he's just sort of fighting and
catching stuff like he catches a car
that's sort of a call back to the
original yes he has an Action Comics
mm-hmm yeah and it just feels like
they're cashing in
on nostalgia rather than using it in a
way that pushes the plot um and I think
you know we're gonna keep bringing up
HBO's Watchmen but I don't know if
you've watched it all yet Tom I know you
had problems I haven't finished it yeah
I mean I need to conclude it definitely
so what what episode are you up to I
think five I think at the age the
exchange on the the farm which you
wanted to buy before that thing dropped
yeah okay so yeah it drank they're all
pretty met episodes they're better on a
rewatch once you know the who-ville
story but from about cell 5 on when it
gets really really good and they start
focusing on like the the following
episode from that is centered around
looking glass and his backstory and you
get to see how the events of the squid
sort of shaped him into hiding behind a
mask and then you have a hooded justice
origin story Tom which I think you'll
really like I've been told it's amazing
and you know someone that we both for
Moya mark been a Dean I think he said it
was his TV episode of the year so
definitely together yes so that yeah and
they sort of take you know original
characters from the original graphic
novel and put them in really interesting
directions that I would never even think
think about this
they're taking the the characters from
the original graphic novel and be like
let's have them have a fight go ahead
Superman and Batman and that's it the
depth of it yeah it's all been building
towards this punch of Superman
destroying dr. Manhattan but they
actually they do a little fake out on
the top they do a little fake out where
it's Lee dude I know I'm skipping over
stuff here like the Lex Luthor thing
which I don't yeah I mean no no you're
right yeah I was I was just trying I
mean just just just to pull back quickly
to one thing I think the the it's funny
you mention about nostalgia and that
idea like I very much hags yeah I did
notice the Action Comics things as well
and the first appearance of Batman as he
drops from the plane almost clean from a
mix between the first 52 issue and you
know the first appearance of Batman
where he's
swinging by that rope and stuff yeah and
he's got a rope in his hand in this one
so I don't know ever again it was
pulling back to kind of the archetype
and heralding my idea
but yeah we we get the punch this fire
guy had someone inside him or something
I seem to remember there was like a lot
of that plot in like every issue seven
or eight but um yeah they have combat
and then we get to the Marfa moment
which I mean like dr. Manhattan did not
give a [ __ ] about Janey Slater like that
was kind of the whole point yeah she was
his anchor and then and then you know
Silk Spectre later and that he became
devoid from that world and like I don't
I just don't believe him caring like
maybe in a certain white race way but
certainly not in a way to like make him
realize you know the errors of his ways
and change his whole fundamental core
that just seems a bit of a
smash-and-grab really I don't believe
that would happen yeah I don't either
um and this fire guy who Superman sakes
saving dr. Manhattan from you wouldn't
have been able to kill him knowingly he
just appears out of nowhere to kind of
divert this punch now I personally Tom
if we're gonna ask me to write Doomsday
Clock okay I think it would have been
better if Batman or Lex Luthor was
trying to stop dr. Manhattan and
Superman had to decide between stopping
them to save his enemy and do the right
thing all that his enemies to come to
his fate but instead they just do a fake
out with some guy on fire they they do
and amidst all this debris despite what
this Hellfire a lightning storm going on
the photos flying around it singed at
the edges but it but it for some reason
it's not evaporated in the pure atomic
energy that's going down it's here and
there I went to take a look at it
we get back into John's eyes and now um
purely just from a you know symbolic
imagery kind of idea I do love these
panels like I really like the Superman
crest de sin
into fluorescent nothing I think that
that looks awesome and I quite like the
boldness of for something so stuffed
Jon's gives over the nine panels to
essentially complete darkness I know
this like traces of life but like I've
never reached seen that in a comic book
before and it did take me back like it's
quite cool yeah it's bad how come this
comic book issue took so long to come
out Tom Beaufort gauges are just black
should be so many like tying moments or
character developments but no we get
here we get into the genesis of Superman
which a few years before that we've gone
for this before and you know I don't
like I you know have multiple issues I
don't really give a [ __ ] about multiple
timelines and world it just kind of it's
caught Blanc really for writers to be
obtuse and over-the-top and when I was
reading this I was almost as quite cool
he's he's trying to codify the Metaverse
and all these worlds into one sort of
way or another and then I've realized
Grant Morrison did this with
Multiversity which idea of leafed
through I think if you seen the
guidebook where he shows you all the
different worlds and yeah it's very cool
like very really good and like I just no
pound for pound Grant Morrison is much
smarter than Geoff Johns and I'm sure he
did it in a much more cohesive way but
I'm not gonna deny the the idea of Clark
landing and are seeing you know the
primordial man and and the snow warriors
and the family like it's quite cool it's
quite cool to see all beside each other
so what it's basically saying is that
the arrival of Superman to earth is sort
of a key moment in every single
multiverse yeah and it's sort of where
things grow from and dr. Manhattan is
now fixing the universe in the same sort
of way that they fixed the universe with
rebirth and made it a bit more hopeful
but yeah it didn't really work for me
Tom no no I read this a couple of times
because I didn't really know yeah I
really don't don't quite understand it
still really like yet from
I gather the nexus point of every world
is Superman mm-hmm and that maybe the
Watchmen universe is its own universe in
the DC what hence the end of the book
with which which we'll get to but yes so
Superman exists the Justice Society
comes back all these things are put into
play that old guy looking for the
Lantern which ends like issue three or
four yeah get his name bees like the
fundable the blue beat or something like
that and this all plays it but it's like
how many because they reference it
themselves as we get further into the
book they reference like rebirth from
Final Crisis and all that it's like as
longtime DC readers just [ __ ] bored
of this like how many times a week later
on the universe upside down again in the
game and again and again like the first
time they did it Infinite Crisis that is
groundbreaking that is so cool and a one
original idea but they just keep trying
to do it but it's like you know the
effect is only gonna be diminished each
time surely yeah definitely
and I've probably read this similar sort
of story about four times now Tom yeah
and I mean if you're a new comic book
reader great but I've seen it I've seen
the verses stories I've seen there were
destroying all the universe and then
bringing them back together under one
single yeah and just to do it with the
Watchmen characters now like that's not
what they were set up for they the
Watchmen characters weren't set up to
like tear apart the universe and put it
back together and reform the DC Universe
it was just kind of a deconstruction of
comic books that was basically what
would happen if comic book characters
were in the real world so the Vietnam
War would have been won by the Americans
nuclear war would start to escalate
because of fear around the world that
there was a superpower
um in in America and they weren't put in
place to think
tear apart the multiverse and build it
back securely so it doesn't feel that
good no it feels it feels like DC's
Cowtown two Watchmen yeah no sorry I
suppose like watchman's Cal town into DC
when reading should have been DC Cal
town two Watchmen
hundred-person and he would have been a
just it always feels inevitable that
they had just just it's a big megaphone
it has to include multiple walls
disintegrating and so we get on these
pages where we see earth to and and all
these different errors and I like how we
get to see that r52 era and and the way
they were drawn and stuff like that and
and by the way listeners out there who
are maybe on a comic book spree after
Christmas in my opinion the best ever
new 52 Ron which was Jeff lemierre's
animal man run has been collected for
the first time in hardcover trade and it
looks fantastic
did you watch near mint condition you
aware that god I don't know yeah he's a
good day he's gonna like comic book
vlogger reviewer dude and he did a good
review on it recently but that looks
really cool I was a little annoyed
really gets the animal man in the midst
but I understand you see bats and all
these different people the every era of
Superman and Superman be in earth and
then I guess death on the following page
which is very reminiscent of like the
Justice League one new 52 coverage and
many other covers where everyone flies
up there at the reader we we teased
future storylines I guess which by the
way it's like secret crisis okay that
that sounds cool flashpoint yeah that
sounds good yes hi masters time master
it's like a [ __ ] all ITV kid show us
I mean you can't believe time masters
yeah it's a yeah it's just been told oh
no death hasn't it really and then I say
yeah it's a crime busters time masters
come on and then I would like setting
these Dayton stone that they're gonna
have to do and it's all like stick to
any schedule line with fire here like
yet it's it's it's just kind of you know
what I was really surprised about that
Frank Miller finished his new Superman
book before Geoff Johns actually
finished this because Frank Miller's
famous for delays and yeah yeah yeah but
yeah this is it's like it's saying like
Superman is a metaphor for hope and
stuff he wasn't when he was first
created he was a metaphor for
immigration now it's just that he's a
metaphor for nothing
eally other than home though he's
everything and nothing yeah yeah and
cause him and his plan was gets revealed
and it was to inspire dr. Manhattan and
come back and save their world by
framing Superman and showing that he's a
good guy
was that it yeah and then he's any it
pretty much was brought his plan to get
soup to get thoughts when had to do that
was the dr. Manhattan had showed mercy
on this couple when their child was
missing or something I didn't kill them
it's it's like it's so tenuous like the
original more Watchmen is so bound like
it's real watertight and that's what
makes it so fun to talk about there's
are so many parallels and echoes and
applying genius and Aziz plan in that is
kind of a traditional supervillain plan
like you know the way that dan dreiberg
hacks into his computer easily and sees
all this maps and stuff but it's done
again in quite an arch ironic way yeah
we're here it's just nothing holds
together under scrutiny at all
yeah well Ozymandias is original plan is
so genius because basically you expect
heroes to you know always tell the
trooper man never lies heroes always
tell the truth and so on but at the end
of the book they have to lie that the
world's like that you know the heroes
have to continue being like if they have
well I know Dan in and Laurie sort of go
off and live their own life which also
gets brought up in this story and but in
that they're kind of bound by this lie
where if they say what's happened then
the world's gonna be ruined so it's kind
of showing that everything is in black
and white you know just because Superman
tells the truth all the time that
wouldn't really work in a real-world
scenario you know governments do do
special ops things secretly that if the
public found out about they'd be very
annoyed about I asked I still can't
believe sometimes that America dropped a
bomb on like a nuclear bomb on Hiroshima
oh yeah just a civilian population they
just flew over and dropped a nuclear
bomb on them
and it's kind of like you know you're
aware of this stuff but you look the
other way because you sort of have to
remain ignorant to it and that's sort of
what Watchmen ends with it's this whole
thing of like well I know this thing
that happens really bad but what if it
hadn't have happened it would have been
worse and where's this plan is just like
come back to my world and save everyone
please I keep doing that voice
throughout this this it's joy know it's
looming yeah yeah it is it is it is very
and you know it's very Bruce whining who
don't really even see young this not
that much I shouldn't mean the main
character it really should have been
finding out what was going on and then
who thinking that dr. Manhattan was an
enemy going to kill him and then
Superman's like I'm gonna stop you that
would have been a good thing and showed
the moral differences between the two
and Superman would have still done the
right thing even if he was suspicious
that dr. Manhattan was a bad guy and
then Doc it still could have had the
same resolve here but it wouldn't have
had all the jumping about it would have
been from a grounded perspective so he
could understand more and it in my
opinion it would have been better but
we'll never get that book now takes all
the characters that we haven't really
dealt with yet you know puts them
outside the Capitol Hill Mazzei again
just tight like teleporting them all at
one play like how do I get these
characters together in a split second
just teleport more yeah all there that's
it so terrible there's no mime in
marionette had been completely forgotten
about they were joyriding at the time
and it's gotta teleport there and then
knowing who on the block feels right
where was the bollocks yeah with some
teleportation thing that takes into
another world and takes him back onto
the yeah unto the opening of the
original yeah call it like oh yeah he's
wasn't anything he didn't have a story
did he know
he really didn't commit I didn't know
anything and it was a big thing at this
start as well that he was alive I mean
he was here that was a huge like USP and
like you consider like in the original
book like how the news vendor has a
great arc you know all that stuff and
like so many minor characters have a
brilliant movements in it but but ya
know not so much here you know
Rorschach reborn tries to get some
revenge on Ozzy that isn't really
resolved it's not quite clear that he'd
what he just sort of became Rorschach
and yeah Manhattan as well says that you
know he has a plan apparently that
they'll see each other they're an anchor
they don't get their kid back and it
just I don't know it's kind of it's
always all box checking you know it's
all kind of tying up things to a certain
extent but none of its you know if it
hits you in the heart and it's not the 9
panel grid at the end which shows how
rush it is he's actually doing
yeah well panels yeah so he travels to
Coleman Carter and caught a Coleman or
whatever he's called and saves him he
says he's gay yeah the Carver Coleman
sorry then yeah he goes to where the
[ __ ] ever he could just goes about
ticking the boxes yeah when he left a
loose thread here so got a ticket um so
Carver calmly becomes the voice of a gay
community he reverses time which who is
can can he do that like dr. Manhattan
was a slave to time and didn't really
have free will
he's not a time traveler definitely not
a time traveler that he can see his life
but you can't go back and be like oh you
know what I was later I'm gonna be nice
to her again yes so with I'm also that
would have like the butterfly in another
the reason why dr. Manhattan doesn't
mess with anything is just because the
butterfly effect and he knows that
everything is preordained it can only
happen in a certain way whereas if he
changes one tiny little event it's going
to have a massive knock-on effect and
yet so that that's a load of [ __ ]
and he wipes himself out as well and
yeah
does he stops himself going into the
intrinsic field is that what happened I
believe so yeah yeah he way calms it
somewhere so he destroys dr. Manhattan
in his universe um so then all of
Watchmen doesn't happen anymore that
book you like Tom didn't happen now yeah
so don't worry about remembering no it
didn't happen didn't happen we just got
50 years of Superman fighting people
comic books we didn't get any
deconstructions or anything tom it
didn't happen delete this part I'm
deleting this podcast right now it's
coming off the enemy and he wipes
himself out stop himself going into the
intrinsic field generator
probably marries Janey it says yeah and
then I think the shot isn't the child
the marionette because you say I didn't
touch him I think he takes the child
it's yes job with Janey and then he
gives his powers to the kids yeah so
again didn't know you could do that
right so what I took this ending as I
might be wrong he realized that Superman
was the you know the linchpin of every
world in the entire universe except for
the Watchmen universe and Superman was
such a positive thing that he every
universe that he went to he changed it
in a positive way and everyone loved him
so he sees it as like well the reason my
universe is so ruined is because it's
got no hope in it because it's never had
a Superman in it so what he does is goes
and steals the mime and marionettes kid
who's gonna be a Superman gives him
superpowers so that he can be a Superman
destroys himself and then leaves his
world with a Superman
that's how I view it so its world yeah
have like a hope to it and everything
like that and it's gonna end up just
another another one in the long string
of universes in the DC Universe I know
yeah this is just like Watchmen one or
whatever this universe is called now or
them the more of us yeah they need to
call it the more of us dead I think I
think I think that would work Annie I'm
sure that would fill him with glee this
is how it ended and I mean that the
final image then John calls me Clark
what do you make about yeah so he's got
superpowers now he's gonna be the
watchman universes Superman and dr.
Manhattan's given him his powers but you
can see by the ring on his head but he's
a nice oh yah man yo it's kind out quite
bad I really yeah yeah oh yeah it's fine
yeah it's still it's still recording
yeah so sorry just say what you're
saying about clock so Clark's giving a
sorry John's giving his powers to this
little clock kid and you can tell
because he's got that ring on his head
and that's it that's he's gonna be
Superman of this universe he's this
universe needed a Superman and he's
gonna be him that's it there he is on
the wooden floorboards so I mean it was
basically everything was building up
here to bring a Superman to the Watchmen
universe that was it you didn't want
something given to this universe you
wanted them to give something to DC and
that to become a definitive part of it
maybe an ongoing series or something at
the end that's what's a big announcement
but ya know it's just
infiltrating Moore's world with further
timelines and mega powers and you know
what does this mean does this mean we're
getting more stories then in this
universe with this Superman or no I
think that's it I think yeah you know
the Superman story just tends to go one
way anyway so we can kind of draw our
own conclusions from that but it's gonna
The Watchmen universe it's not gonna end
the way that it was in the original
story because
there's a Superman here and you know
he's a great guy he's not gonna be like
a dr. Manhattan he's gonna be a great
guy for the planet so yeah brilliant
but then also how right if this so if
this was all reckon then why I Laurie
and Dan disguised as the Hollis is still
yeah that makes sense actually really
doesn't really make sense when you look
at it yeah no no it doesn't and it
doesn't have to Altima if it's like a
moving tale but you know maybe you know
cuz let's think about how the original
Watchmen ends with Rorschach's diary and
everything you know is potentially about
to boil over like maybe there's a
certain inference here with this boy
that you know all might not be what it
seems and it could go haywire and but I
like you said I don't think so I think
this is just the end it's a cute it's a
cute little ending to throw there and we
get a rabindranath tagore quo you know
the Indian poet and again with John's he
just takes it really on face value every
child come to the message that God is
not yet discouraged of man you know the
illusions of God of Manhattan and
creation and again it's fine no back
material bar a Carver Coleman Hall of
Fame star which I mean I don't care
about this guy like I'm supposed to
listen any like sense of sorrow like in
wise he got that photo Janey and John
trod on yes so that's it what what a
stinking disappointment boy I almost
felt it was gonna be back from the half
so I can't say I'm sir I had a Manhattan
like vision of you know the continuity
and it was just it was always gonna be
this way there from afraid yeah
and you've actually got the Superman
cape draping over the Watchmen clock at
the end to show us right Superman he's
better than watch bitten yes
essentially yet but yeah that's it three
years or two years sober
and was it worth it oh my god I mean if
only if I don't need to speak to you
I'll Chum every now and then it was but
in terms of that me enjoying it no no it
was a complete waste of time
yeah it just feels like they didn't just
drop the ball from me off didn't stick
to deadlines didn't really know where
the plot was going
this was meant to set up a lot of things
in the DC Universe and it like obviously
hasn't because it's taken so long to
come out um and yeah just feels like it
dude it's just ya know I'm glad it's
over but I didn't enjoy it that makes
sense
oh there's one thing I just mention as
well that I think we've glossed over
quickly
page 34 when they're talking about time
masters and all that it's quite an
interesting thing here on July 10th
twenty thirty the secret crisis begins
throwing Superman into a brawl across
the universe with for himself and a
green behemoth stronger than even
doomsday obviously Hulk so he's that
hinting at another crossover or maybe
that would be good on it because of yeah
yeah they've done all of the verses that
they can in the DC Universe so maybe so
they're gonna have to swap over at some
point yeah these days welcome Tom left
upcoming storylines
yeah yep that's it that's it and they
look good
yes secret crazies that must because
obviously damn mob will do secret stuff
and DC do promise yeah like these pod
question yeah we'll do it we'll do it
then and then we'll never do it yeah
yeah yeah what secret crisis was a thing
but it but it's not I just googled it so
yeah who knows
yeah there's a few there's a few news
things about that online that are better
saying is this teasing it so you know
clearly clearly is but um yeah I mean
obviously comment down below cookies
were you thought of this book
go back and check out all of our other
reviews we spent a long time detecting
this piece of hot garbage and go through
all our other discussions you know you
may not be aware that me and deaf
certainly the best thing I think we've
ever done we spoke to the colorist of
the original Watchmen John Higgins which
is a fantastic chat and you know still
really really proud of that but yet I
mean definitely final words are Doomsday
Clock everything ends tom unless it
keeps going everything does mm-hmm like
this yeah it will probably be back in a
couple of months hopefully they do is
see the second season of Watchmen on HBO
hopefully okay I don't think they are
Tom I think Damon Lindelof said he
doesn't want to but it does end on a
cliffhanger so and you know a bit
Hollywood in that they're bankrupt ideas
wise at the moment so everything's
getting brought back I've been like
Gavin and Stacey yeah yeah that exactly
I've got a stand and explain to that and
I would say well I don't either
he said yes or he said no it's not yeah
any much text yeah and I don't know you
can explain the uh you could explain the
fishing trip you can go into all the
clues from the show on that big yeah but
but yeah guys I guess the final thing I
want to say is in the last ones as I
spoke to death I have started another
new podcast this is a bit different this
is actually a game show podcast it's a
pun wordplay game show called Punnett
I've had many people on battle rappers
and such and friends of mine and it's
getting a good response over there so
you know go check that out
and obviously heavy spoilers stay
subscribe death pumping out that stuff
for you and yes I mean we'll have to
speak about something else you know the
end as we are technically done now we
don't we do for the last like almost
four years we've had this ongoing
obligation to do Watchmen do Doomsday
Clock did it I guess before Watchmen
even though it's even though it is
complete crap we should still do it well
this was complete crap Tom and we still
did it so yeah maybe we'll do meet you
me you know what listeners stick around
because we might be doing before
Watchmen I've got I've got all the
stories I haven't read them I bought
them about three years ago when we
started this podcast yeah so I suppose
we'll have to get round in them yeah I
guess
wait what would you have to be ankle of
the graphic novel be all together now
we've completed it we're no doom-doom
yeah man I'm not even joking probably
like a two or a free really like this
vet this very like are twice like if we
just looking at a holistic clay looking
on everything like art wise brilliant my
school that individually probably eight
or nine like it's not quite to my taste
but like it's incredibly done yeah Gary
Franks is a real talent but in terms of
story so convoluted and lumpy and Megara
venti and I don't hopefully Geoff Johns
is a good writer at all really and I'm
not even like even though I love watch
when I'm not being this little fanboy
over what to try to do even nothing it's
been terrible
just taking it on its own merit as a
story um it's it's just been boring
ultimately it's slow and turgid and and
really unrewarding like you know twelve
issues so I'm not what time you got to
put into this and normally you don't
begrudge that because it flies by but
here I really found myself looking at
the page numbers I mean like how long
have we [ __ ] got you know what I mean
it's just like yeah mom and it was quite
a work quite short issues a lot of the
time they were about 20 pages long and I
had the same thing where I say finally
got the end of it get in and yeah feel
the same very you know you've got a
direct comparison of it as well they
released this issue in the same week as
the HBO Watchmen finale and yeah it was
night and day the difference between
them one you could tell they really
thought out everything from the start
and initially the HBO Watchmen you know
it did seem like they were just throwing
[ __ ] at the wall but it really came
together really well well as this just
there's a Superman and what nothing
really mattered anymore I hate that I
hate when they wreck on everything and
they get rid of it
especially when it's like a classic um
and yet not rewarding at all if you
wanted the Watchmen graphic novel they
mean nothing
congratulations here's your book if you
didn't yeah Eddie then yeah it [ __ ] yeah
if you hate it if the original Watchmen
and you wish Lee it was expunged from
the canons of law then you're in for a
treat and it is good too I just had a
quick look on comic book roundup the
sort of rotten tomatos thing and this
this is the second lowest rated book of
the 12 it still Stuber 8 but it looks
like there's quite a lot of bad reviews
actually a lot of fives and sixes quite
a lot appeared responses which is what
you want to see a lot of people saying
how the disappointed how the Watchmen
characters feel like filler and this is
more just a kind of giant metal
narrative that they were just pawns in
which is totally true like you know you
got embody Watchmen and then [ __ ] do
a multiple world story like it's just
it's not what you know this is a panel
like it is around that grounded gritty
reality and that very similar to so um
yeah au revoir I will say good riddance
[ __ ] them and it's a good night Frank we
take care everyone Cheers